[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically win with your money win in
your work and win in your
relationships phone number to jump in is
88255 225 that's
88255 225 I'm k colan George camel joins
me we're Ramy personalities co-host of
the show good friends and I want to say
as we start just a big congratulations
it is launch week we'll talk more about
George's brand new soon Tobe
best-selling book Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress fabulous book
congratulations pal your first book
launched this week it's been very
humbling and overwhelming in the best
ways well it's kind of like uh another
type of baby and you're a new dad so now
so yeah it is very is a lot of similar
baby about 4 and a half months ago both
keep you up at night that's true you
know you I'm not sure which one was more
difficult at this point at least for me
that's true maybe the book at this point
my wife will have a different story than
to Whitney that's right all right let's
get to the phones we'd love to talk with
you George is here to answer your money
questions I'll weigh in I'm here to
answer any questions around your work
and making more money George will weigh
in on those as well let's go to Kelly in
Indianapolis Indiana Kelly how can we
help
uh hi I have uh I've been kind of
following the Ramy plan for just trying
trying to follow it for uh maybe about
uh a year couple year or two but I just
have one last credit card I just can't
quite seem to uh get rid of I don't have
a balance but I'm just trying to
convince myself to actually get rid of
it I love this and Kelly I'm I break
this down in the new book into eight
different characters so can you tell me
which one you fall into is it out of
fear is it for the rewards is it the
convenience what is causing you to go I
I can't cut this thing
up I feel like it's more like the maybe
the pressure of like everyone said like
you should always have one you're
because you never know if you're going
to get stuck in a situation where you're
going to need it okay so for you I'm
going to call you the emergency shelter
that's the sixth personality in the book
I need my credit card in case of
emergencies right
probably yeah okay well let me tell you
there's a way better emergency fund and
it's where you become the bank instead
of Capital One and that's called an
emergency fund do you have a $1,000 save
for baby step
one uh I do I'm actually in a four and
six wonderful so how much money do you
have in
savings I have uh just a little over
like almost 11,000 amazing now tell me
one was the last time you had an $1,000
emergency uh never exactly so a lot of
this is paranoia there's fear we have to
deal with and the other piece of the
equation is you have insurance that will
transfer the risk you have things called
deductibles and outof pocket maximums
and so you're going to be protected and
you don't need these credit card
companies anymore they were never your
friend and it's just a rubber crutch and
it's only a matter of time before they
come knocking saying hey Kelly we'll
come save you at 22%
APR Kelly is the $111,000 does that
represent 3 months 4 months 5 months or
6 months of your expenses uh more like
closer to three yeah is there a number
that let's say George and I were were
feeling uh like we could just cut a
check here let's say we were having
Dave's money here we like to give Dave's
money away I like that you and I have
done it a lot uh in our role that's true
we really have uh let's say George and I
could cut a check right now okay and it
would add to the $1,000 in your
emergency fund and when we cut that
check and you deposit it you would go
I'm cutting this credit card up I I feel
so much better is there a
number that we would add to the 11,000
be realistic here what's the number that
if we wrote a check to add to the 11,000
giving you a total of in your emergency
phone where you'd go okay I I don't need
this stupid credit card just curious
what's that
number I guess maybe uh maybe another
9,000 to make it 20 all right now George
you see what I'm doing there Absolutely
I'll give it back to you you're some
facts on the security gland which is
largely feelings and we just said if you
had 20 grand you would feel so secure it
would be a force field between you and
life and that would be more like six
months of expenses
correct yeah probably so then I I'm not
saying you have to do that Kelly but I
did a little experiment there cuz that's
what George and I are trying to get you
to I think 11 is enough for for you to
cut the credit card up well that's what
we think that's why we teach what we
teach should have credit up a l we
should have cut it up when you did baby
step one $1,000 that's what we teach but
why not then why not put the 9,000 in if
that makes you feel better and it
removes the Temptation I say go for it
that's the thing Kelly if you cut up the
card today and an emergency happened
what would you
do you would dip into the emergency fund
money yeah and that's what it's there
for and then once you use it what are
you going to do after you use it you're
going to replenish
it you know it didn't happen you never
went into debt you were never at the
mercy of the credit card companies who
are supposed to be blessing you with
your 2% cash back and this emergency
shelter and so I'm going to encourage
you to do the brave thing and what's
amazing to me Kelly is as people have
been reading the credit card chapter in
my new book they're telling me for years
we couldn't cut it up and you finally
coaxed us into it with all of the
research and humor and every objection
I've ever had I address it in that
chapter so I'm going to send you a copy
of the book and I want you to read that
and then send me a DM when you cut it up
with a picture can you do that for
me sure that's all I ask in return so
hang on the line Austin is going to pick
up and we'll make sure you get a copy of
Breaking Free from broke it's chapter
three specifically and uh Ken I want to
do another little mindset trick if I
might George I want you to join me on
this you are like the David Blaine of I
don't think show but Kelly you said
something at the start of the call
when George was asking you what's
holding you back from cutting this up
and what you told him was what other
people are going to say to me CU other
people in your life are saying Kelly
you're a they're not using that
language but that's how you feel but
they're going Kelly it's silly to cut
the credit card up in case something
were to happen and so you haven't cut it
up because you're worried about what
they'll say but what
if what if something happens and when
they hear about it they're like like
what what did you do you went I cut a
check cuz I had it in the bank or you
said well I kept that credit card thanks
to you and I put it on the credit card I
got to pay it off quick cuz it's about
23% interest which of those two answers
are your friends and family going to be
impressed with the most you tell
me probably the F the first
one so Kelly you're not going to be
viewed as silly Kelly you're to be
viewed as smart Kelly by the very people
you're worried about and being
criticized by true or
false true there it is and guess what
those friends are normal Ken normal's
broke we know four out of 10 people have
nothing in savings 25% of people have to
use the credit card to cover the bills
that's not Kelly you've unsubscribed
from normal and fear is a terrible
financial adviser and so these credit
cards you know using other people's
money actually makes you feel less in
control because your body's keeping in
the score it knows that you're not truly
safe when you borrow someone else's
money when you don't use debt you got
less stress and you become the bank
Kelly that's what we want for you we'll
send you a copy of the book Breaking
Free from broke let me know what you
think of the credit card chapter and
send me a photo or even better a video
of you cutting up that last credit card
I love it this brand new baby is coming
your way Kelly for the rest of you can
get it right now wherever books are sold
or at ramsy solutions.com don't move
we're just getting warmed up in frigid
Franklin Tennessee this is the Ramy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus A5 ,000 seller guarantee gives your
offer the best chance of being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel and
we are here for you this hour 88255 225
George taking your money questions I'll
take any work related questions cuz that
has a lot to do with your income and
your mental health and your emotional
health it affects pretty much every
considering how many hours of your life
you spend working that's right so I want
to help you out those areas if you're
thinking about some kind of transition
this year you're just not happy there
you're trying to figure out do I start a
side hustle is this the year to do it
can I do it while I'm in the baby steps
any kind of work rated question I'd love
to help out on that and George Will as
well8 825 5225 let's go to Austin Texas
Chris is there Chris how can we
help hey Ken thanks for having me on man
you bet what's up um I've got a question
regarding we're trying to kind of
restructure our debt and everything so
for my wife did really well this year
and her commission and bonus coming here
in a couple months is going to be about
$52,000 whoa way to go wife that's
pretty phenomenal you were pretty happy
when you found out about that weren't
you oh absolutely
absolutely um so one of the big things
that we're knocking down is the
remaining credit card debt which we have
about $111,000 just under with that that
we're going to knock out and then the
next things we kind of want to
restructure our vehicle loans so um I
own my own business uh I'm in
distribution of Beverage concentrate so
last
year about two years ago it was pretty
tough getting a rental car a rental van
so I went ahead and purchased a truck
ended up paying $63,000 for that truck
at a $893 a month payment and it's been
fine because it's been overall savings I
mean versus paying you know $1,500 a
month renting bands back then but we're
thinking about go we're going to get rid
of that truck um no matter what we do
because Vans are available today but we
all we do have negative equity of about
I would say about 13 to $14,000 in that
truck just because car manufacturers are
getting competitive right now um and a
new truck would sell for $3,000 less
than the one I have with 44,000 miles on
it so my question you two was is we have
a Ram
1500 um and a Jeep Wrangler the ram is
8.93 a month and the Jeep Wrangler a
662 so the first thought that I had was
to go ahead and pay the negative equity
um on the truck and purchase a new
vehicle and we would basically assume a
new loan on that new vehicle so if we
found a car for
$25,000 um we could go ahead and pay the
negative equity of the truck of let's
say
$133,000 are you talking about the Ram
or you talking about the van because I'm
getting confused here you said a van and
then a I thought you said a ram truck
and a
Jeep yeah so I have a ram truck and a
Jeep the reason why I purchased the
truck was because I used to rent vans
okay it took the place of a van it took
the place okay I just want to make sure
there weren't three vehicles in this
conversation so the what you've been
telling us is the ram is the one uh that
you've got the 11,000 excuse me the 13
to $14,000 negative equity on yes okay
go
ahead um so what I was thinking is we
have two options so we can pay the
negative equity by trading in the Ram uh
towards a new vehicle for her and we're
setting ourselves a $25,000 budget and
then what we would go ahead and do is
just pay that negative equity and then
pay for that car cash and then keep the
Jeep payment of $662 a month or the
other option was to go ahead and pay off
the Jeep which has a remaining balance
of
16326 and then pay the negative equity
in the truck and put a bit of a decent
down payment on that new vehicle and
take out a new loan trying to get our
monthly payment down to about 400 a
month 450 a month well I I'm GNA let
George George I only want to weigh in on
one issue okay I I just want to weigh in
on the Jeep sure those cars do not hold
up well and so whatever your advice
you're going to give him I I personally
would pay off the Jeep and sell it or
sell it if you've got do you have
negative equity on the Jeep or you got a
little equity in that
um no I have I have I'd say about
$118,000 equity in the Jeep dude I'd
sell the Jeep those things I'm not
trying to knock Jeep and I don't want to
get any hate mail but I'm just telling
you I'd get rid of that I'd sell that
for sure anyway George go ahead the one
issue that oh there's not an issue with
it it's just that so the jeep was a
long-term goal for us to be able to even
purchase one and we use it we just had a
our first son about a year and a half
ago but prior to that we use it about
six times a year um going camping and
going Offroad
and so we made the commitment that this
is the one vehicle that we're never
going to sell it's
actually reasoning for not selling it is
because you use it six times a year yeah
it's not a strong
case well no it's a daily driver so we
do use it to go to work and things like
that but it's a recreational vehicle in
the sense that for six times a year get
you a little Honda cord for the daily
driver and go rent whatever the heck you
want with your amazing income six times
a year that's right so let's walk
through the numbers let me let me figure
out some options for you you're getting
52,000 in the bonus uh you're going to
have to pay taxes out of
that uh no that's going to be gross
income so you're gonna have toay tax
sorry not gross net that's net okay so
let's say we are the only debts you have
the two car loans and the credit
cards yes okay so we we knock out the
11k credit cards we move on to the
16,000 Wrangler that leaves you with 25k
correct yeah yes now we pay off the
negative equity it's another 13k out of
that leaving you with 12 but now you can
sell the
RAM and you'll have yes you'll get out
scotf free I don't think I would trade
it in because the dealership's going to
screw you on that 100% so you're going
to get way more private party and
probably not be as underwater as you
think if you do it that
way yeah and the dealership will
convince you that you need a nicer car
than the one you currently looking for
and they're going say wa if you're going
to spend 25 Grand might as well spend 35
get some something new that is how
dealerships work and so I would
encourage you to not purchase it from
that dealership and instead search for a
quality used vehicle that you can pay
$112,000 for in with the remainder in
cash okay and it's not going to be the
prettiest vehicle but what's your
household
income um so just a standard salary
we're looking at about
138,000 a year that's good money dude
think about this yeah but he's getting
good money for the ram George yeah but
when you think about it this way you
spend 12 Grand on a cash car now you
have no payments in the world making 138
how quickly can you save up an upgrade
in car and doing cash yeah versus
trading in debt for more debt but we're
lessening the debt I'm like dude you
guys make good money you could solve
this thing with this bonus what a
blessing let's just be done with it
instead of playing the debt
game yeah exactly that's that's what I
would do if I was in your shoes cuz
you're calling me telling me hey we make
great money but here we are with
payments all over the place and you guys
have been able to justify every single
one of these but I think we're done with
justification I think we're ready for
Freedom
instead yeah no that's that's exactly
where we want to get to you can find a
$112,000 truck it ain't going to be
fancy but for what you guys are using it
for it's a work truck
right yeah well and I'm going back to
renting a van when I do my he's not
going to need it it's going to be his
driver just his regular driver then just
get something reasonable for your daily
driving another yeah another reason that
we're trying get out of the truck too is
you know our son as he grew was a little
easier when he has a baby to put him in
the truck and everything and my wife's
actually pretty small and she has an
issue getting them up in the truck and
she doesn't like it she just thinks it's
big and a SW so I relate I relate to
that yeah this is how Whitney treats
George every time she has a hard time
getting George up into the van so they
went to a
sedan sick of the booster
seat we joke Chris but I I think we got
to start making decisions for what's
best for our family 10 years from now
instead of hey well the kids and this we
just got to make future thinking
decisions and they all need to require
cash and no debt once you take that off
the table it's going to change the
decisions you make it's going to change
your level of sacrifice so you guys are
this is going to be all done so soon if
you do it this way but I would not trade
debt for a little less debt I don't like
that game when you guys can get out of
the scotf free mhm yeah and and get us
San get something or a small SUV
whatever you know you got one kid right
George did I get that right so you know
what's gonna happen kids going to throw
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich on
the floor all these all these young
couples want to get the nicest car for
their kids and toddlers let me tell you
something the amount of goldfish that
are going to be in the floorboard and
cram between the seats the smarty
candies I could go on on pretzels you'll
be on a Lord of the Rings quest to try
to find all the crumbs in that
car well said goodness C and by the way
they don't make the attachments on the
vacuum cleaner that you need to truly
get all those little gold get all the
nooks and crannies yeah it's not going
to happen really good stuff all right
don't move we're going to take a quick
break back with more of your calls this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys Ramsey solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to net Suite it works for us
and it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million dollar company
netw weite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netsuite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman George camell joins me
thrilled that you are with us the phone
number is 8825 5225 8825 5225 taking
your money questions uh life questions
work related your professional Journey
questions uh we're here for you this
hour let's go to Joseph now who joins us
in Cleveland Ohio Joseph how can we help
today hello thank you for taking my call
you bet what's up
Joseph I just recent start just recently
started going through baby steps I'm on
baby step two and as I've been starting
to share my goal of paying off all my
debt with family and friends they've
I've received a fair amount of push back
on why I shouldn't do that and I wanted
to see if you had any advice on how I
could have respectful conversations with
my family and friends while also being
clear about my goals with
them man well uh you're not the first
one to experience this when uh broke
people are giving you p push back about
your financial plan it means you're off
to a good start but you know I always
love the quote the best revenge of
success here and so I think you just
stop talking to them about it I mean why
do we have to have these arguments just
go live your life get out of debt and uh
when you've got peace and no payments
and they're all looking at you going man
you got a little pep in your step what's
going on Joseph you go I got no payments
they go I guess that plan actually
worked huh what was that book oh Total
Money Makeover okay that's how these
things usually go so what kind of push
back are they giving
you uh it's typically
that um I have a little bit of credit
card debt and then the bigger one is my
car payment okay and so a lot of what
I've received is well you should keep
your car payments over time so that you
can build your credit and use the money
that you could put towards that to do
other things and you share DNA with
these
people ouch uh yeah for some of them
yeah do you understand that so not nice
but if you explain the credit score to
them and you went hey let's talk about
this credit score idea what do credit
scores do they allow you to get more
debt and what does getting more debt do
when you play the game perfectly you get
a higher score and what does that do it
helps you get more debt and so if your
goal Joseph is to not accumulate debt
cuz we know the pain that it causes
millions of Americans everyone's broke
then I'm going to run the other
direction and if they don't understand
that that's okay not everyone has to
totally get what you're doing here for
sure do you agree with them when they
say these
things uh no cuz I'm I'm I can feel the
excitement within me of the prospect of
not having any debt and being able to
save and and do things um and just the
idea of Le trying to you know quote
unquote wisely leverage debt or anything
like that just it sounds sounds awful to
me so no I don't agree with them at all
okay so uh who is they do you mind tell
us who yeah I have one of like probably
like my best friend has given me a lot
of push back and I've kind of floated
the idea of paying off debt to some
family members um that I'm close with
that I trust and do respect but on this
we seem to have disagreement yeah is
there another Topic in life um that you
don't like to talk to anybody about or
there's very few people you'll talk to
it about like politics or something like
that I'm just curious any other
something you go I just I don't want to
get into that with people is there
something like that for
you um I can't think of anything
specific off the top of my mind this
needs to be one of those
things okay I think you need to take
George's advice I think he's absolutely
right I think you need to stop talking
to your best friend about this stuff
treat it like you know some weird
conversation and you just go I want
nothing to do with that and I'm going to
create some boundaries I change the
subject I just think and same thing with
these other family members if you
disagree with them them then don't bring
it up okay I can just tell you without
embarrassing any of my there's a couple
of my family members that I can't talk
to about certain public figures that's
all I'm going to say I leave the room I
don't even want to I don't even want to
touch it George because it's just it's
not it's a land mine what's the point
well but I'm we're not going to agree so
it's I'm we're past the point of
fighting I'm not worried about a fight
but it's just a waste of time and
emotional en% I'm not going to
therefore I don't want to have the
conversation and I think George this is
one of those topics agreed it's why I
don't talk to you about sports Ken we're
not going to get anywhere you're not
going to teach me what a play action
pass is because you'll never be able to
understand it that again is another
waste of energy but I hope you get that
Joseph so hey you keep your eye on the
prize follow the baby steps because you
believe in it and you believe that it's
going to make a better life for you and
by the way it's your life and so all
folus focus on that and and and just no
more talking to everybody else unless
someone pays my bills they don't get a
vote yeah and so I'm just going to go
thanks Mom and Dad friend Uncle broke
cousins I'm good I'm going to try this
plan and if I fail successfully by
getting out of debt and it's terrible I
can always get more of it yeah but uh no
one's ever come to me and said that so
that's a tough one when people don't get
what you're doing when you're a salmon
swimming Upstream all the other salmon
are going dude what are you we're going
this way man this is the path and you're
like no that's a cliff my friend and
there's a giant bear right there about
ready to eat you Bears love salmon yes
they do I I Pi Capital One is the Bear
in that metaphor they're all heading
toward the Capitol One Cliff yeah those
commercials are so windome they just
make it seem so nice you know well you
got Jennifer Garner smiling at she's the
sweetest person on the planet you know
good move getting away from Alec Baldwin
you know what I mean 100% yeah let's go
to Sydney in Atlanta Georgia Sydney how
can we
help hey thank you for uh taking my call
you bet Sydney what's going on
so I um just need help with pretty much
everything um I'm 24 I bought uh my
first house when I was 20 um for
$997,000 um it was just an older couple
that wanted to sell it CU they were
couldn't take care of it anymore um so I
have a mortgage um I have a boyfriend
that lives with me we have a daughter
she's a year old um we have a car
payment you know we don't have any
credit card debt um but we do have like
a couple of small loans um we just can't
seem to catch up we can't seem to save
anything um and I'm just tired
of chasing and chasing and never being
able to make any
progress what's your
income um so
I uh stay at home with our daughter
because our
where we live uh our daycare system
around here is just not trustworthy and
it would take like half of my paycheck
to take or pay for daycare anyway um so
I stay home with her and U my boyfriend
brings about 50,000 um but I do have a
business myself but that only made a
whole whopping like $6,000 last year so
okay so you guys are making 56k and what
are your payments add up to because so
far you've got some personal loans the
car loan and the
mortgage if you added those
up I have a car that's paid off but it's
always in the shop so that's our only
hesitation with selling his car um his
car has 14,000 left on it um the house
has 88 left on it um and then I have a
part of my business I have a sewing
machine that's on um uh on our loan and
um
um it's it was originally like $1,500
it's got like a thousand left on it but
I'm planning on paying that off soon
okay as well as a computer how much do
you guys have in
savings um we we barely have a th in
savings
okay well I feel your pain uh luckily
you guys have a small mortgage and so
we're going to ignore that right now if
you added up your car the car loan and
the personal loans on the sewing machine
computer are we talking 15
$166,000 um no like I said there's the
sewing machine's only 1100 left and the
computer is like 500 So Okay cool so
it's about
15.5 is what I'm adding up to so here's
what you're going to do we're going to
lay these out smallest to largest we're
not going to get overwhelmed by the big
picture and we need to get this income
up if that means your boyfriend is doing
side hustles for the next 6 months to
clean up this mess great if it means
selling the car and getting something
cheaper to get around in right now great
but this is a this is a solvable problem
you make 56 we're trying to pay off 15
how quickly can we do it how do we get
that margin we got to make more we have
to spend less and if that means you
going back to work for a little bit even
if daycare you're going to net an extra
500 bucks that's going to help finding
finding a grandmother in the area that
wants to make a little money wants to
get out of the house that you can trust
and she watches the child in your home
go make more money this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why ref IFI they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me we're
here for you America the phone number is
88255 2258
225 uh this is big news George got to
mention this uh because I just got the
email a couple days ago uh we've got a
brand new event uh entitled Total Money
Makeover pretty good idea Total Money
Makeover weekend May 10th and 11th named
after the bestselling book that's ever
come out of Ramsey Solutions Dave's
unbelievable classic Total Money
Makeover and so in one weekend you're
going to crash course on everything we
teach about money uh brand new content
from all of us Ramsey personalities and
uh this is a great great event because
no matter what baby step you're on it's
going to fire you up going to have a lot
of Q&A time with all the personalities
and uh that's always really really fun
we just get to hang with you early birg
tickets started just
$99 uh but this is only for a limited
time get your tickets now at ramsy
solutions.com events that's ramsy
solutions.com events always fun I'm
pumped for this when we have it here on
our campus rumor has it you could
witness smart money happy hour live with
Rachel Cruz and I on Friday night and a
special guest Ken I think it's time is
this the event I'm
going I'm it's a soft pitch but uh you
have talked about having me on and I
thought to
myself I don't know if your regular
audience wants the special guest that
much I think it's time but I think at a
live event you me Rachel cocktails and
uh that's what get butts and seats for
The Total Money Makeover weekend I'm in
I don't know that it will that is a
great deal for an entire weekend event
right here at the headquarters it'll be
fun just I'm th I'm putting it out there
I won't Lobby you thank you all right
very good Kayla's up in Atlanta Georgia
Kayla how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call you
bet what's up today
Kayla so I'm a college student um
getting a biology degree and initially I
was going to go to demal school but I'm
not really too interested in getting you
know just a ton of student debt yeah
good for you so I've always wanted to be
an entrepreneur so I prayed on it and I
just decided that I wanted to start a
clothing line so I took a business
course and she was basically you know
just telling how to secure business
funding and stuff like that and I know
you know how you all feel about you know
business loans but I created a business
plan and but I didn't know that they
asked for like collateral and stuff like
that right so my parents aren't too
interested in you know putting their
house up for collateral so now I'm just
like I don't know what to do now like I
be financially free I'm glad you called
so you haven't taken out any loans out
correct no okay so Caleb business
funding is just fancy for a loan and now
you know that and and so can I just
encourage you that you don't need a loan
nor do you need a ton of capital to
launch a business in America today now
the clothing business I would tell you
that's a that's a pretty high risk very
competitive world would you agree with
that
statement yes so if you were to go get a
bunch of loans with a great business
plan all the collateral all the things
that you don't want to do and you're
right by the way you would still have a
tremendous amount of risk and so how do
we remove the risk by a small test now
do you plan to design the
clothing yes what are you thinking if in
your business plan did you did you um
did you highlight uh two or three
different articles of
clothing yes what were you
thinking um like just matching fits um I
already talked to like a manufacturer to
find a manufacturer to find out you know
how much it would be to get them okay
what did you find out were about $30 a
piece like for the matching top and the
matching bottom so 60 bucks for this
matching outfit is this casual wear is
it what is
it um yes it's casual wear and no
together they're both they equal up to
30 oh okay so your hard costs on both
top bottom are $30 and what have you
found out in the market as you were
putting this business plan together that
this type of combo this outfit what's
the what's the uh uh wholesale or uh
retail
price um about 115 115 that's what your
competitors are doing for something
similar yes okay well it's a pretty good
margin but still you get into
Manufacturing and I don't know if you've
read the story if you haven't you should
you should pull anything you can online
there's a lot of it out there on Sarah
blakeley's story she's lives in the
Atlanta area and Sarah is the founder of
Spanx have you heard of
her yes you need to read her story
there's a lot of hustle and and effort
on this and I my point here is you need
to start smaller than than ride out of
the gate with your dream item I love the
ideal item of the top and the bottom and
you know and it's casual wear and it's
comfy and we retail for
115 but there's a lot that goes into
that and you're going to have minimums
that you're going to be required to
upfront with the manufacturer because
he's got manufacturing company's going
to get paid up front or or at least a
portion upfront right I'm not a super
expert on this but I know the basics and
so I'm just walking you through this so
there will be some upfront capital and
it needs to be cash so to the extent
that you can get out of college start
working save up a bunch of cash to get
to a point where you go okay I can at
least invest this amount of cash and I'm
going to go with one or two items I'm
going to go online and I'm going to try
some things that's the long term what
can do in the short term with maybe some
jewelry or a t-shirt or a sweatshirt or
something that you can test out online I
want to bring George in here because he
really understands this world I weirdly
do and very entrepreneu holding back so
I wanted to bring you in at this point
and and now walk her through what would
be a uh let's call it a a lowrisk
economical test well the way I think
about this Kayla is you can't just get
out there and be like I have clothes for
$100 why why should they buy yours over
the brand that they know and so you need
to create some unique value proposition
here and I would start by creating an
audience do you have a big Instagram
following Tik Tok following um somewhat
somewhat yes so I would focus on that
and it doesn't have to be clothing you
made if you have good style I assume
you're very stylish and your friends
compliment you on your outfits I think
she sounds like she's very stylish so I
would start doing outfit of the day
here's how I pick these outfits here's
the the idea behind it here's my
wardrobe here's some deals I found on
clothes that I love and you start to
become sort of a fashion influencer now
all of a sudden you build up a following
of 40,000 people Brands want to work
with you you're getting money from that
now you can launch your own line that's
how all the people I've seen actually do
it
successfully and that's okay that's not
going to happen tomorrow right this is a
6 Monon 2ye 5 there's also no debt baked
into that
Kayla you know start small is what we're
getting at start small grow slow um this
is not going to be your day job coming
out of college and I'm not saying that
to shatter your dreams I'm saying that
to support your dreams your day job will
support the side hustle until you can
get the boat close to the dock to where
that side housle now makes more than
your day job or close and you can now
pursue it fulltime are you tracking with
us are we making
sense yes um I just I mean at the end of
this month I'm going to be getting my
refund check it's about $9,000 so I was
wondering if I should use some of that
to um invest into the business or
whatever but it's just that my rent is
it my refund check does also cover my
rent so I was wondering if I should like
ask my parents if they can support me a
little bit on the rent while I use do
no and do you have an emergency fund
fully funded um no that's where that
goes I think that refund just became
your emergency fund once you have no
debt and an emergency fund of 3 to six
months of expenses now we can begin
investing for the future in retirement
and a Roth IRA and for this business
Kayla listen I know you're grasping what
we're saying but you went right back to
I need to ask Mom and Dad for help to
pay my rent so I can you listen you
don't need to use the 9,000 right now
that 9,000 as a safety net in the form
of an emergency fund for a graduating
college student is phenomenal you're
head of the game no debt now go get a
really good paying job two or three
paying jobs and start doing what George
is talking about where we test the idea
of can I figure out how to sell clothing
for a profit post pictures of it and say
would you buy this or would you buy this
and start to test this out it's exactly
we just took a call this week this
couple took out $200,000 in small
business loans the business failed now
they're getting jobs and they're
freaking out and I don't want that for
our friend it's like a penalty for
trying something that's not how it needs
to be in America but just adds emotional
and financial pain on top of the failure
of the business yeah if you do it right
it's the American dream not the American
nightmare but no debt folks all right
good hour thank you George Campell thank
you James Childs and all the guys in the
booth that keep us on the air thank you
America for listening this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically winning with your money in
your work and in your relationships I'm
Kim Coleman George Campbell my good
friend is here with me this hour 8825
5225 8825 5225 George will lead and
guide on the money questions I'm here to
chime in on on any of those questions
plus the work related questions not
happy in your work want to make some
more money bigger shovel how do I make
more income in 2024 I'm here for that as
well and uh also very excited this is uh
the last uh weekday of georg's launch
week Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress look at that that's a fabulous
looking book right there the or cover
regardless of my face on it yeah the
team did a great job you got a great
face George thank you well it's been a
fun week the the feedback has been
amazing the reviews are pouring in and
there was a guy on the live stream we
did yesterday the Q&A for the book
launch 51 years old and he had tears and
he was going this book gave me hope that
it's not too late for me wow he's in
customer service in Kentucky he's got
some debt to pay off and I'm glad I
could give him that hope and I told him
his name is Calvin I said call the show
today so Calvin if you're out there
hopefully Calvin will call call us up
cuz I said Ken's going to be able to
help you with this work stuff oh boy and
help you make more income I hope so to
clean up this mess I love it well really
good and very excited for you George
it's going to help a lot of people a new
generation of people that never heard of
Total Money Makeover are going to really
be helped with Breaking Free from broke
you can get it at ramseys solutions.com
or anywhere books are sold all right
let's go to my old stomping grounds when
I worked for the governor of Virginia
wow Richmond Virginia area is where
Austin joins us Austin how could we
help uh Hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call you bet what's up um
actually we've me and my wife we've uh
we're in bit of a debt but I keep seeing
all this um stuff about S&P 500 and how
if you in your 30s if you start in your
30s you can put like $100 a month and
whatnot and I want to know if that would
be a good idea to start doing that
knowing that we're still in
debt how much debt do you
have
222,000 whoa that's a bit to you
wow
190 of it
31,000 yeah 31,800 is uh is um a private
loan and credit card and then and then
plus my wife's car and then the 191,000
is for our house and then I have 11 left
on my
car okay so we got two car loans and and
credit cards and personal
loans just one personal loan and One
credit card yes sir okay and what does
just the Consumer Debt add up to if you
take out the
mortgage
uh right at 40 right at 43,000 great so
that's the number I want you to to
tattoo in your mind right now how much
money do you guys make okay per
year um she makes around 50 I actually
on disability but I I make around 19 and
then um I actually am able to do this uh
delivery order thing so I can make an
extra 1,100 a month so I make around
19,000 not including the uh 12,000
that's not guaranteed every month okay
so maybe we'll call that 30 60 69,000
yeah yeah yeah so 30 for you 50 for her
we're going to call that 80 and we got
43 to pay off so now this becomes a
little math equation going how quickly
can we pay off 43 make an 80 of course
after
taxes MH now focused on the Consumer
Debt instead of the mortgage and go how
much margin do we have outside of our
normal bills that we could create to
throw with this debt cuz I'm looking at
this going could you after taxes this
become 55 60,000 you guys are working
with yes sir yeah right around so we're
talking five grand a month what's your
mortgage
payment
,450 okay so once you subtract your
normal bills your Basics we're talking
food utility shelter Transportation
Insurance do you have an extra pile of
money at the end of each month or are
you guys in the
red we're we're almost in the red yes
very very close to it because of all the
debt
payments uh that oh well the credit card
is the main thing because that you know
the uh interest rate is outrageous so
that's the main thing we're working on
um but we can't work on it too much so
basically what I like every ounce of
income I make outside whenever I'm doing
deliveries or things like that I throw
all that straight towards the credit
card because the interest rate is just
so high and so little actually goes to
the um to the principal you know and the
rest goes to the interest
so talking about all this do you see why
investing right now is not a good
idea yes you don't have any money that's
why I was so
curious do you know how you could get
more money to
invest no if you freed up all those debt
payments what would that add up to in
your life these consumer debts that
43,000 free up all those payments is
that like an extra th000 bucks a month
in your life oh yeah you could do some
investing with an extra thousand bucks
and no payments right right yes sir so
we're going to get you back to investing
I know you said you're in your
30s I'm 33 and my wife's 30 okay I'm 34
and let me tell you you can pop on to
our investing calculator and go all
right we're going to be debt free in 2
years and then 6 to 12 months later
we're going to have a fully funded
emergency fund so you will be what 36
years old by then yes big whoop and
you're going to be investing 15% of your
household income which for you guys
about 80 grand so let's say 12 Grand a
year right
okay and let's say you're starting with
zero I'm using this calculator right now
to show you from age this is pretty
mind-blowing um yeah I want you to share
this because I'm looking at a ey popping
number here on your
screen okay you ready for this from age
36 to age 60 if you start with zero and
that's age 60 most people will work
beyond that 1,200 bucks a month cuz
remember you're going to invest 15% of
your income which is about 15 grand at
10% rate of return return like you said
the S&P 500 on average 10 to 12% since
its Inception you would have $1.5
million at age 60 holy okay and that's
and that's if you start three years from
now Austin but can I tell you what most
people do most people keep fiddling with
debt they're investing 2% 3% putting
money in acorns and some spare change
hoping they're going to have money one
day instead our plan says hey one thing
at a time focus on the debt focus on the
emergency fund then we can get to invest
with a Vengeance so that's what I want
for you and I think you'll get there in
no time but continue getting that income
up that's a huge part of it so can I do
a little exercise let's do with you um
and I'm trying to think of the person
who's maybe listening going I'm not
young I'm not 33 34 let's put in age 50
okay let's make up let's let's uh let's
say 50 to 67 is that fair age 50 to age
67 okay and let's what what's a uh let's
take a um a reasonable salary the 15% uh
what do you think is the right number I
think 70 grand is average in America for
household 70 grand okay so we're talking
15% is 105 105 which is Ken if you're
doing the math at home going to be 875 a
month so 875 a month let's say you
started with zero 50 at age 50 you start
with zero and you invest 875 a month at
10% you would have almost half a million
dollars that's extraordinary at 11% over
half a million at 12% you would have
almost 600,000 that's what thanks for
doing that cuz I want people to
understand it you know it's not too late
you can really make up some ground uh
and that's on a very reasonable number
there so really fun stuff yeah most
people in their 50s are at the top of
their salary yeah absolutely fantastic
it is doable great call Austin you guys
are going to be okay just follow the
plan all right don't move I'm George
actually I'm Ken Coleman you're George
camel I don't know what's happen love I
know one thing this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
save up to 35% off everything sitewide
that's blinds.com to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me 8825
5225 is the number thrilled that you're
with us Grace is joining us now in
Jacksonville Florida Grace how can we
help hi thank you for taking my call you
bet
um so I'm calling for two reasons today
uh the first are my best friends Alyssa
and Brian completed baby step number two
today so I wanted to give them a shout
out a what's their names again Alyssa
and Brian Alyssa and Brian way to go you
guys are rockar
hello absolutely um but my husband and I
actually have a question as well uh
we've been working the baby steps and
have two paid off Vehicles a car and a
Truck we have a baby on the way so the
truck won't be conducive to our
family um we are wondering if we should
sell the truck and throw the money at
our student
loans could you just live with one car
is that the
plan for a bit until we save up to pay
in cash for our next vehicle um I think
we could do that yeah okay what's left
on the student
loans well so far we've paid off 100K in
total between our cars and the loans and
we have 40K left awesome so this will be
knocked out pretty quick what's your
household
income household income is 150k love it
and what's the truck
worth the truck is probably worth 16k
right now at the low end okay so if you
sell it for 16 it'll knock your student
loans down to 24
yeah that's correct okay so it just help
you speed this up but it's not going to
be a you're not knocking it out
completely do you have any other
savings uh we have our emergency fund
and that's about it we're full-blown
doing the baby step okay because one
thing I'm going to mention is while
you're having a kid we call this stor
mode and we tell people hey pause the
debt snowball you need to save up and
just stack up cash until mom and baby
are home healthy so that you have money
to cover any unexpected medical expenses
okay so I might uh you know hold off and
save up as much cash as you can when
when's the baby doe the 4th of July woo
wow very exciting Ken loves that he
loves Independence Day I do I'm trying
not to break out into the star spangle
Banner right now I'm going to where's
Lee Greenwood when you need him yeah
don't get me started there we go so uh I
think you guys are on to something here
selling the truck if you don't need it
and I would stack up as much cash as you
can and then at that point we can sell
the truck we can clean up the student
loans and making 150 do you guys just
have the student loan payment right
now yeah that's it that's our only debt
okay awesome we do have a mortgage sure
well I think I would set a goal for how
quickly you're going to clean up the
student loan I mean it would be amazing
if you could clean up the student loan
and have the emergency savings by the
time baby's here depending on what your
income is doing well we're tracking uh
having the student loans cleared right
about when the baby's here or shortly
after we pay about 40 or 4,000 a
month okay that's how much you're s
you're able to throw at it yes that's
that's fantastic well if you can sell
the truck clean up the student loans and
have an emergency fund in place by the
time baby's here then I would I would go
with that
plan that's the goal that's a fun
aggressive goal yeah you guys are on on
track that's exciting love it and love
the shout out for their friends that's
that's really cool a good friend right
there that's that's a great tribe to be
a part of people that are getting out of
debt and taking control of their money
let's go now to Salt Lake City Utah
Grayson is on the line Grayson how can
we
help hey so I've listened to your guys'
show just a little bit here and there
some videos on Facebook and that kind of
thing and um I feel like you know it's a
lot of times about these big bets and
those kinds of scenarios and me and my
wife you know we're young we're just
trying to get started we're both in
school and we're trying to figure out
the best ways to get into like a routine
budget and get started on investing in
that kind of thing you know setting
longterm goals
cool so where are you guys at
financially right now what's the
household
income yeah so it varies um on a
month-to-month basis just because we
both work part-time and you know hours
vary a lot so I as I look back over the
last couple of months it's probably
somewhere between 2500 to like 4500 give
or
cake okay and that's your net income or
gross yeah net okay cool and what are
you guys doing for
work I left high school basketball and
my wife works as a CNA for a senior care
center how much do you make ref in high
school basketball it's $62 a game
actually okay and you full-time student
did I hear yeah okay all right when will
you both
graduate next spring if everything goes
on track okay and then your incomes will
go up after that yeah cool and how much
debt do you guys
have uh the only thing that we have is
my car and my parents um they bought it
out right for it in cash and I've just
been paying them ever since and there's
about $9,000 left on that and you just
owe that to your family with no real
terms and conditions right yeah okay how
much do you have in
savings uh 8500 oh wow well this debts
almost gone I would uh once once you got
10 I'd pay that off and have the th000
left for your starter emergency
fund okay and that'll clean up your debt
right so you both would have no debt at
that point yeah okay and then we can
begin to build a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
so looking at your budget I would go
through all of the expenses add those up
for one month on a given month it costs
us $3,000 to cover all of our basic
bills let's have 6 months that's 18
Grand we need to focus on on saving
up okay that's probably going to take
you guys another 12
months sounds about right yeah okay so
about a year from now you're ready to
invest because you have no payments in
the world and you have a bunch of money
ready to protect you that's going to
feel good isn't it yeah and you said you
guys are young how old are you two uh
I'm 21 my wife uh is 19 she turns 20 in
a couple weeks oh my goodness think
about that 22 and 20 years old no
payments fully funded emergency fund
you're graduating your income's going to
go up now we can begin investing 15% of
our income at that point and really
start to build some
wealth that' be nice yeah and and you
talked about starting your marriage on
the right foot goodness gracious man
having no debt payments and an emergency
fund is going to help you avoid about
90% of your marital
fights that's the goal I we've wondered
too though with you know both of our
work situations we would really like to
get a second car we've been holding it
off obviously as much as possible
because we don't want to go into debt
but we also like having a savings
account that we can you know just have
in case we need something what would you
guys recommend in that scenario of you
know how if we need a second car how do
we go about getting one um you need more
money you buy the car you can afford in
cash and if you don't like that car you
need to keep saving and you to keep
living off one car but those are your
only two options
yep do not go into debt so one of the
things that will help you here is I
because we say things like that and you
go okay I get it but what you need to
start looking at is what would 7,000 buy
me I'm randomly picking a number what
would 10,000 buy me what would 12,000
buy me in Salt Lake City start shopping
okay uh you can go look at used cars go
under 15,000 under 10 under whatever and
just begin to go okay ah all right so
now we have a Target because it's really
hard to to chase something that's not
clear and so if we go okay I I I I saw a
couple cars and I think I think babe if
we come up with 10 grand we're be able
to get you a gr car or whatever okay now
we have a very clear goal so now all of
a sudden you go what must I do to get 10
grand extra in cash well I'm going to be
ring more basketball games or I'm doing
something different you know uh I'm
selling anything that I got or whatever
so now we go okay we work backwards it's
just reverse engineering good $10,000
car 8 to 10 is going to get us a pretty
solid car for us so that's what we got
to come up with and so now you have a
very clear attainable goal that's how
you accomplish stuff like that got it
yeah that makes sense all right you're a
sharp young man congratulations on uh
being in a situation like this where
they're young married couple their whole
future in front of them George and in
good shape yeah 21 years old that's
amazing he's getting this stuff now if
he actually does the stuff we just
taught him he's going to be a
multi-millionaire with a wonderful
marriage you think back to the last
segment when you got out the old
investment calculator they are not far
from being able to invest and just
really I thought reap the benefit for a
second you were about to go coach some
basketball k and you're like hey this is
a good side gig love to see coach
Coleman out there yeah I mean look 62
bucks a game isn't bad but he needs more
money than that this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back America you're joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman George camel is with me and
we're here for youle
8825 5225 8825
5225 the ramsy show question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly offers a
helpful uh w a helpful minder
maintenance checklist that's not written
right uh you can download for free at
neighbor.com and for the more
challenging stuff in it around your home
and that's basically everything for me
everything George is an extra challenge
for everything is a challenge for us
neighborly has local Pros to help find
out more at neighbor.com
Ramsey today's question comes from Jason
in Virginia my wife and I have taken the
FPU class we have no debt and we own a
home worth
$270,000 I feel like the focus of your
programs are directed toward people who
live in upper middle class we live in
the country we Homestead we grow a lot
of our own food and I work full-time and
side jobs my wife cares for her elderly
mother full-time we hire assistant
career to give my wife one day a week to
get out of the house but when I look
over the list that I'm supposed to be
living up to I feel as if I have failed
I've never worked a job that has a
retirement plan I've never had a large
income I feel God has blessed us but my
present retirement plan is work till you
die woo wow that's a
strategy well I think let me say this
before you break the money part down you
know I believe we were made made to work
and I think that there's certainly um in
in the older season of your life you
certainly want a downshift yes but not
doing anything working to a point to
keep your mind active is certainly
certainly helpful so I understand like I
we were talking about this the other day
Stacy and I with our retirement planner
and he's like Ken you're work until
you're 70 and I go
70 like I I want to be putzing around
driving around still putting a suit on
trying to get myself together in the
morning to go do something speak
communicate something well into my 70s
uh so to that end I don't want to poo
poo this idea uh but um but sounds
cynicism to it yeah something's off here
on this I'm going to have to work until
I die yeah which is different uh so he
says he's taking FPU they have no debt
they have a home worth 270
he says he's never worked a job that has
a retirement plan let me make it clear
to everyone out there just because your
job doesn't have a retirement plan
doesn't mean you shouldn't be investing
or that you can't invest there are lots
of ways to do this if you're
self-employed there's SE IRAs and solo
401 case anyone with earned income can
contribute to a Roth IRA or a backdoor
Roth IRA if your income's too high and
so there's no excuse to just not be
investing there's even taxable brokerage
accounts outside of retirement that you
can just shovel money away to grow with
compound interest so I don't like this
idea that well I don't have a retirement
plan so I don't invest so we need to
start I don't know how old you guys are
it doesn't say here um but if she has an
elderly mother it tells me they can't be
that old and so I would get on the get
on the ball here and start investing and
start having a plan to where you get to
work but you don't have to work yeah
it's a very different mentality yeah
great advice uh thank you Jason uh get
your chin up a little bit I I would I
just want to address something very
quickly our baby steps are not in any
way designed for upper middle class I I
do want to address that uh I I would say
they work for all classes and let's not
forget by the way that there are more
sixf figure earners in America right now
living paycheck to paycheck than any
other time in American history so uh
that's upper class upper middle class
middle class and and down so this is we
see the stories we see people who now
when they start the baby steps they tell
us yeah we were making 40,000 60,000
80,000 and we did side jobs and we got
our income up and we got the promotion
we switched careers all of that's going
to help you get to that six-figure
household level but the average
household in America is 70 grand yeah
and you can do this plan making 70 grand
that's exactly right it's just
discipline and it's just understanding
the baby steps that they work together
and once you get momentum we've seen
this uh what's the latest data on on
people that take FPU how much they are
able to pay off and save I believe it's
like $8,000 turnaround between the debt
paid and dollar saved yeah and see
here's my point once you really get this
system and you begin to Experience
Momentum right it may come momentum may
look like getting that first thousand
for some people for others it's knocking
out two or three of the debts in the
baby in baby step two but it's kind of
like you ever had a Pringles George you
just have you ever just had one Pringle
no once you pop you just can't stop
that's the T that's the tagline and so
same thing once you get going in the
baby steps the momentum just builds and
builds and builds and and it's doable so
that's so true well other plans out
there Ken it's like the financial plan
is like cottage cheese I'm like I
wouldn't even take a a spoon of that
it's not interesting to me it's not who
want cottage cheese don't even know
what's in there too much Cottage that's
it let's go to AJ who's in Buffalo New
York AJ how can we
help good how you guys doing today good
are you in the Buffalo
area well not at the moment currently my
wife and I travel for work so okay we're
kind of up and down the East Coast right
now well you know what I was thinking
I'm a big football fan I was looking at
the playoff game last year and all that
last week all that snow and just insane
what you folks do deal with up there you
guys are incredible yeah we get like 8
Ines here and it's like apocalyptic you
guys no problem yeah it's a Tuesday so
how can we help
AJ so right now my wife uh she's got out
of work I just picked her up and we were
kind of going back and forth um the two
paths we're looking at right now we're
looking to settle down start a family
you know we don't want to wait too much
longer you know we just turned 31 uh
both of us and right now we have either
the path of settling down getting my
wife a new job because she is a traveler
uh
Andor buying a house settling down
whatnot Andor we have been given the
option to purchase a a a fitness center
and we're trying to figure out which
financially is going to make most sense
for us at this
point tell me about the fitness center
uh before we get to a job for her what's
the fitness center
situation so I previously come from a a
fitness background and whatnot and it's
always been my goal to potentially down
the road at some point own a gy um it's
kind of something we've always toyed
with with the option if it's something
you know maybe like a passive income
Source or something you know down the
road for us and um
we kind of got given the option to
potentially buy a gym and we wouldn't
need to take a loan out on it so we're
trying to figure out if that is the
correct move for us um it'd be an owner
operator gym for us so my wife would
take over that position as a manager
there um is that gym profitable right
now yes how
profitable uh so overall net as far as
cash flow probably talking like 250 a
year okay and how familiar are you with
the ins and outs and operations of
running a
gym uh not super familiar yeah yeah I I
got I got warning signs yeah I got
warning signs uh because of two things
number one um how much would you have to
take out what would be the loan
amount uh about 500,000 yeah that's
crazy to me you have no experience at
all um it's not spitting out a lot of
profit 250 is pretty low margin and you
said passive income no chance running a
gym is is about a passive is running a
marathon it it it's just not a passive
income model and so there's just a
couple of signs and again I'm not AJ in
any way trying to be unkind or uh I love
the entrepreneurial vision
I don't want you to take course we don't
we don't tell anybody to take out loans
so the answer on that is no but it's
just not a good business to get
into given the fact that you have no
experience in it and you're thinking
it's a passive income model I'll give it
back to George here but I I I would
rather your wife go get a really good
paying job and let's forget about gym
ownership or owning any company right
now that we have no experience in at
all George is that too is that too uh
no I just I think anytime we have we're
presented with the option or the
opportunity to go half a million dollars
into debt I I go red flag red flag yikes
I would pause and go how do we do this
the right way how do we cash flow this
this might be a plan that you do 10
years from now when you can save up that
kind of money but we just had a call
this week AJ they took out 200 Grand in
SBA Loans the business failed they're
working regular jobs and they're screwed
now they're freaking out and half a
million is over double that so you got
to think about the wha ifs and not just
get star eyed about what could be yeah
save up cash if you want to get into
business save up the cash just start it
the right way save up a lot of cash to
buy something that's already profitable
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campell joins me the
phone number is 8825 5225 if you want to
join us for taking your money questions
your questions about your work your
income that big shovel that we've called
it for decades let's go to Michael now
who joins us in Sacramento California
Michael how can we
help hey guys how's it going good how
are you sir doing good better than I
deserve as David would say there you
go um hey so quick question on
specifically baby step number six um for
in terms of paying off the house uh we
have a pretty low in uh pretty low uh
interest rate at about
3.375 um so that being said does it make
more sense to put all the monthly
payment like extra monthly payments
towards the house um and like
installments or um I was curious about
maybe Throwing It All In A A you know
high yield savings or like an index fund
or something and then just getting up
the lump sum and kind of paying it off
in one
go great question Michael um and I love
that you're actively trying to pay this
house down and we get this question a
lot right now because people do have
these lower interest mortgages you know
sub 5% and their savings accounts are
making 5% so they're saying why would I
even pay off the mortgage but your
question is should I sock away the money
in the high yield savings and at the end
of the year throw that at the
mortgage correct so mathematically I'd
have to be looking at the amortization
schedule and get super nerdy but you can
do that with your own numbers I don't
think it's going to make any
mathematical sense to do that like the
spread just isn't worth for the $100
because your interest on your mortgage
payment is going to be calculated
monthly so the sooner we knock that
principal down the less interest we're
going to pay every month and you'll
notice the interest is sort of
front-loaded with that mortgage payment
so when you first start paying down the
mortgage you're not making any progress
CU most of that is going toward interest
so the sooner we can start flipping the
scales here and getting most of the
money going toward principle the less
interest you're going to pay the faster
the mortgage is going to get paid off so
I'll tell you what I did we just put
extra money on top of the principal
payment every single month so once a
month if it was on the first and the
mortgage was two grand let's try to put
an extra Grand that month on top of the
principle and so that I think is the
best and simplest method with the least
amount of brain
calories okay that makes sense so so
even if we were to be able to get into
an index fund or something and even pull
it up from like five to 5% to say like
10% or whatever uh you would still just
suggest paying it off monthly and not
not going through what's your time
Horizon for this
uh well so I I have a my salary is about
115 uh that I get paid monthly and then
I have a side business um that I also I
get about three to 5,000 on that um so
right now we're kind of in the space
where we can live pretty comfortably on
uh the salary um and not touch the side
stuff as much uh so it it like I said it
varies some months it's two some months
it could be three or five or seven or
whatever um so the thought was to just
put any of that extra
towards you know whichever way we decide
to go put that towards the
mortgage um and so we owe about 330 or
so so I was kind of doing some of the
math on it and um you know if we average
out like three grand a month extra that
we're paying I think it's going to end
up being about like a five or eight year
maybe uh time span so it's going to be a
a minute you know because we're not
going to get it paid off right away
anyway so that's where I wasn't sure if
you know long term could that interest
start kind of building up and working in
our favor versus uh you know pay away at
the 337 paying down the mortgage now is
going to be a forced savings plan which
I love and putting the money in an
investment account you're adding a whole
lot of risk to the equation because we
don't know what that account's going to
look like in a few years and so I would
rather just pay this down now cut down
the amount of Interest you're paying
every month and it is going to be so
encouraging and freeing to see that
interest go down to see the principal go
down see more going toward this mortgage
actually getting paid off so I would
just do it every single month instead of
waiting in a lump sum and the other
thing that happens is you have this
money sitting in an index fund in an
investment account and all of a sudden
you go well we could really redo the
kitchen with this money should we really
pay it down the house that's what happen
psychologically speaking Michael um
that's just human nature so I like the
force Savings Plan of just saying every
single month whatever extra we can
muster up we're throwing at the mortgage
and it's going to be more motivating too
cuz you're not going to see that
Mortgage Balance go down by doing it the
other way
definitely yeah that makes sense so
that's what I would encourage and it's
what I've done personally and it's how
my wife and I have paid off our mortgage
and I have no regrets of the wh ifs of
what if I invested that money or put it
in the savings account to make the
spread it's not interesting to me well
the point that you're making here is
that the a paid off house or investing
in your house by paying it down is a
much safer play than even an index fund
as good as that return is long term well
and think about it if you pay off the
mortgage faster now we free fre up the
mortgage payment to now invest in the
index fund for the rest of our life both
so people think well I would rather
invest we're we've still been investing
15% of our income the whole time you're
paying down the house that's baby step
four and six so great question let's go
to Hunter now in Salt Lake City Hunter
how can we
help hey guys thanks for having me sure
what's
up so I have a a career question so just
a little bit of background I finished a
degree in Healthcare Management within
the last year and just recently uh last
month actually I accepted a position to
manage a primary care clinic in Salt
Lake um and honestly it's just kind of
not feeling right I've been working in
healthcare for the past three years or
so um but I'm just wondering if it's a
bad idea for to look into a career
change after only being in this position
for about a month might be let's figur
it out what what's giving you pause
what's making you question this
direction you just went to school for
this you got a job in this sounds like
and a month in you're going whoa what
what is going on there give me give me
the give me the rough the rough the
roughest part of this that's causing you
to question
it well honestly I I don't feel like
I've ever been that passionate about the
work like when I was working I was
working in a separate Clinic before and
honestly I really liked the people and
when I was going to school for it I like
the people I was going to school with
and everything I just don't feel like
I'm necessarily passionate for the work
and this Clinic that I've just started
at just doesn't have a very good culture
I don't okay so we we don't like the
people it's okay to say right yeah
that's part of it well then I would
certainly not make a pivot out of this
career Lane just based on that you know
it's kind of like saying uh I've been
married a month and we had our first
fight I think I'm want a
divorce like whoa yeah wait a second
here like that's part of the deal right
there's going to be some days where you
don't love your wife so much right but
you choose to love her anyway and vice
versa so I think in this situation it
would absolutely be premature because
because but I will tell you there's a
what I would call a yellow flag waving
the yellow flag is that you were never
really passionate about this work anyway
sounds like you chose this as a safe
professional path is that about
right yeah that's right well I will tell
you the odds are that eventually we're
going to make a pivot anyway but but
let's but let's stay let's kind of like
stay still for a moment and and realize
that okay I'm an adult I made my bed I
got to sleep in it and either I stay in
this Health Care side of things the
healthc Care Management side of things I
move maybe uh six months from now a year
from now to a better culture so that I
don't look like a flake because I got to
keep this resume and I got to keep this
professional image intact so that I can
keep climbing you understand that yes
yes and now I'm going to figure out okay
what is that pivot let me do the hard
work now that I should have done in
college I'm going to give you by the way
two tools I'm going to give you my get
clear career assessment and I'm going to
give you the book from paycheck to
purpose they go together the assessment
is like a compass and the book from
paycheck to purpose is like the field
guide to climb the mountain does that
make
sense yeah it does yeah so I'm going to
give you those two resources because
here's what you're trying to figure
out how can I use what I do best that's
your talent to do work I love you
mentioned passion that's what that is to
do work you really enjoy to then produce
a result that you care deeply about this
is where meaningful work comes into play
right I see that I enjoy the work but I
also am very very proud and and and I
feel very significant because of the
result that I'm
creating that's the answer to use what
you do best to do what you love to
produce results that matter do you get
that yeah it sounds great that my man is
what I'm all about helping people figure
out I'm going to give you those two
tools hang on the line Austin will get
them to you now listen here's the key
stay where you are now okay until we can
figure out where we want to go next
right now you're just dealing with a bad
culture and you're just going to be a
big boy put your big boy pants on and
learn how to deal with it and if we make
a temporary move that leads us to a
long-term play that's that's the goal
George Campell good hour Hunter thank
you for the call James Childs and the
crew thank you guys this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and in your relationships the phone
number is
88255 225 he is George camel I'm Ken
Coleman thrilled that you guys are
hanging out with us today George is our
money expert and the author of a brand
new and soon to be
best-selling author status like this is
this book it's called Breaking Free from
broke and uh you know look I like to
make predictions cuz honestly George is
cuz I don't mind being wrong you know
what I me that's fair I hope you're not
wrong I don't think I'm going to be I
think this going to be a bestseller I
think it's going to be a number one I'm
going to project that we got another
week we're we're wrapping up the first
week of pre-sale so here's the deal uh
if you're new to the program and you
love and let's be honest there's no way
that you're not new to the program and
you don't love George he's just that
lovable this is the new book breaking
through Breaking Free rather from broke
the Ultimate Guide to more money less
stress by the way you can get it at
Ramsey solutions.com or anywhere books
are sold and George give me 10 seconds
on the book can you give me 10 seconds I
believe the system is designed to keep
you broke and it's not all of your fault
but it's your responsibility to rise
above the system and live with more
margin more freedom more options and
totally unplugged from this toxic money
culture of debt yeah it's going to help
a lot of people so get it now Breaking
Free from broke Ramy solutions.com
wherever books are sold all right let's
go to Cincinnati Ohio Jack is there Jack
how can we
help Hi how are you guys good how are
you sir I'm good I wanted to get your
input on a impending house purchase for
my family and I we have been Ren for uh
right now and um we are going to be
moving for a new job in a few months and
we've been looking at houses in the $6
to $900,000
range but I feel like our our financial
situation is a little bit unique and so
I wanted to make sure that my
calculations for that being a reasonable
budget are correct okay lay it out for
us so the bad news is I have
$250,000 in student loans The Good the
good news is I've got zero credit card
debt zero car debt and I used that
student loan to become a doctor ah what
kind of a doctor
so um let's just keep it to I'm in one
of the higher paying Specialties so I
okay very nice landed my I'll call it
dream job and so in in a few months
we'll be moving for that and my new
salary is going to be $600,000 a year
congratulations all right that's that's
the good news on top of the
250 we still get to
250,000 yeah so obviously we're we're
planning on trying to pay that off in a
year or less good wow good for you and
so I wanted
to make sure that you know we we buy a
house that will not inhibit our ability
to pay that off as fast as possible so
why not I'm going to lay out a different
option just option b right now or C
where you rent for a year where you're
going to move to and you use that year
to pay off the debt to get an emergency
fund to build up a down payment it might
even be two years of renting what would
be wrong with that move yeah we we have
considered that the the main reason why
we don't want to do that is because we
have been moving quite frequently for
the last decade uh it's kind of a how
things go with the U medical training
process and so we are sick of moving and
you know just we're longing to be able
to settle down somewhere and um get a
community and not have to upload our
lives every two years can I push back on
that that's the main thing let me push
back on that and I first of all I
understand it totally get it Ken has
done some moves in his day I have uh
Jack I toally understand but you've done
it this much over the last decade you
can do it one more time and I think
that's what George is proposing you even
hire some of those high-end movers that
move all of like they'll unpack the junk
drawer and put it back in your new junk
drawer yeah I love that but but just
even higher up the ladder on the
priority list than that I love that
George is right you can get great movers
it's not that big of a deal however
you're moving to a new area starting a
new job I would not put the added
pressure do you have
kids yes yeah see I Stacy and I when we
mooved now so let me tell you so you
know that I'm saying this from
experience this is what I would do when
when Stacey and I moved back here nine
years ago we had lived here for three
years no kids uh we move away to Atlanta
Dave brings me back to join the team
here nine years ago it's going to be 10
years in June and we rented for 2 years
because this time around even though we
had lived here 3 years before it had
been 11 years in that Gap George and we
had three kids now two of which were
school age one was going to be starting
kindergarten and we just said you know
we're going to rent and resettle and get
a lay of the land and I think even more
so because of all the moves you guys
have made in the last 10 years I I would
rent I like George's I like George's
suggestion for two reasons One Financial
he's right absolutely about that two
gives you guys some time so that when
you settle your
settled yeah we are familiar with the
area we're going to be moving to so it's
not like we're it's a totally blind move
but you know all right you know what I
still go with George we are considering
doing that path I was just curious if if
if that number but you're you're
considering taking on potentially a
$700,000 mortgage or more yeah it's
going to put you a million or more in
debt so it's going to be harder to pay
off the student loans rent is going to
be cheaper no matter where you're going
when you're carrying that kind of debt
and I I recommend you do this with a
15year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay now that parameter
you won't struggle with because of your
amazing income but I also recommend you
guys save up 20% down so think about
your next goals we got to clean up the
debt we need a fully funded emergency
fund of 6 months we need a down payment
of 20% we just have some priorities here
and so that's why I don't recommend
jumping into the house you'll be there
in no time and I understand moving one
more time is going to be a pain but when
you do it our way it's going to give you
so much more peace and margin a smaller
mortgage that you're going to knock out
more quickly and then you can afford all
the home renovations and emergencies and
the HVAC and all that stuff will just be
a slight
inconvenience that's our take Jack
probably what you wanted to hear what
are you thinking before you call us what
number were you thinking about spending
on a house which means
lending I'm sorry what were you thinking
price-wise when you called us that you
thought well I think I can do this let
me call George and Ken and let's see
what they think what what what number
were you putting on the house the the
the average that of houses we've been
looking at online has been around
700 yeah well what would that put you
how would that strain you would that
strain you at all or do you feel about
that 700,000 how much could you put
down I think that we would be able to um
we would not be able to put much down at
all um but so you move in with no equity
whatsoever with a bigger mortgage I mean
we're talking if you did 700,000 with
nothing down you're talking $7500 $8,000
on this mortgage every month where you
could rent for two or three in a nice
place so I'm doing that while you clean
up this mess but you'll be there no time
you make over 600 Grand it's
mindboggling it's going to be a blink of
an eye before you're in that house yeah
I I agree with you George I think uh
Jack if you can just trust George's
advice on this I think you're going to
come out feeling so much better on this
deal have a great house no debt this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
you're listening to and you're watching
the ramsy show we're coming to you from
our worldwide headquarters in Franklin
Tennessee just a little bit south of
Nashville I know you like what I say
worldwide I just thought to myself yeah
this is the international headquarters
if you'd like to you know hype it up a
little bit it is there is no other to be
fair people visit us from all over the
world now which is really fun so if
you're around the Nashville Tennessee
area make us a part of your trip we'd
love to have you we come out in the
lobby and sign books and take pictures
and you can get free coffee and bake
goods and a mug and we make it a whole
experience for we really do it is a lot
of fun and we have some brave souls out
here today uh it's a winter wonderland
uh all of a sudden in the Nashville area
so uh you know uh glad you're with us no
matter where you're listening how you're
listening or watching triple 8255 225 is
the number let's go to the Big Apple
Christopher joins us there Christoph how
can we
help yes hi sir I appreciate you guys
answering my call um I'm just uh kind of
in a situation um and I want to learn
how to kind of start my life
independently and also manage my
finances uh at the age of
23 okay can you be more specific what
what challenges can we help you through
now at the age of 23 that you're
thinking
through so um I was living with my
father from the time I moved in uh from
the age of the 15 to 22 uh we were just
living in an apartment together he
passed um in September of 2022 so I was
22 oh so sorry for that
loss I appreciate that sir thank you and
um pretty much uh from there I um I kind
of stayed in that apartment for a while
just ran free and I eventually got
evicted and um I had to move in with my
uncle so he that was back in April of
2023 so not even a year ago and um
Whatchamacallit so I've been living with
my uncle so my dad's brother uh now
for uh about eight months and um he also
has his health elment like ailments as
well uh like you know he has COPD he's
been on oxygen for 26 years he's 7 years
old so he's limited um his time is
limited um and basically you know he's
he's actually in the hospital right now
um it's just me and him living in an
apartment um he's going to be okay but I
just want to uh kind of just plan for
the future you know what you doing for a
living as of right now I'm just a shift
supervisor making $18 an hour uh at you
know it's like a fast casual restaurant
here in New Jersey okay what are you
making per year
um I couldn't tell you I would assume
it's a very low income such as I
wouldn't say it's more than 25 is this
part-time
year uh no it's actually full-time it's
18 an hour 40 hours a week okay so
you're making about 36 is Grand gross
pay but one of the things I want to come
back is coming back to 25 yeah
Christopher the fact that you don't know
means you you don't have any kind of
budget and that's going to hold you back
no matter what the professional goals
are we'll get to that so what do you
want to do do you have any sense of the
direction that you want to take I do
100% what is that I've never been too uh
interested in you know any type of
profession the only passionate thing
I've ever really found in my life was uh
health and fitness um so I have a
license as a like a certification for to
be a personal trainer through um this
progr progr called
maim um I have that under my belt can
you go work the gym and work your way up
to being personal trainer at the
gym sorry what was that sir can you go
work at a gym even if it's for $18 an
hour right now to get into that field
yeah of course yeah 100% what's keeping
you from doing
that
um I don't know I think uh I nothing
really aside myself I think I took the
loss um
you know a year and a half ago kind of
rough and it's just been you know
affecting me in more ways mentally than
I realized and it kind of you know
because as as as a personal trainer it's
mainly predicated upon sales yeah so you
have to go and talk talk up to clients
and you know you can't be shy you have
to be
extroverted and yeah I I'm sure you guys
get the point yeah um so how can we help
you today how can we help
so basically sir um I have 45 Grand uh
is in an State account left behind by my
father I'm very thankful for that
um and that's essentially it I have the
ability to work um I'm willing to do
whatever kind of jobs I need to earn
money um do you have any
debt the only debt that I know of that I
have is 1,500 so 1,500 in uh credit card
debt and maybe I took out a few years
ago to uh do Comm try Community College
um some fast for loans it's like kind of
lower
income uh household you know to send you
to Community College I might have that
might catch up with me in the future but
Christopher here's what I want you to do
because you you don't really know what's
going on go to annualcreditreport.com
and you can pull your credit report for
free from all three bureaus and that's
going to tell you exactly what you owe
you need a very clear picture right now
instead of just thinking and feeling
what's going on and then use that money
that your father left you to clean up
the debt and get an emergency fun in
place I think long term you need to get
out of the situation and rent on your
own with some roommates cuz I know it's
New Jersey it's expensive but I would
rather you rent with a guy your age
who's on a similar path versus um this
situation man you got to grieve you've
had a lot of hard stuff happen and I
think it's sort of just held you back
which is fine but need to form a path to
move forward and that means cleaning up
the debt get the emergency fund
switching our career we got to get some
mojo back man yeah Christopher no 100%
you said something a minute ago that I
want to challenge you on because you
called today and so I want to honor your
time and the fact that You' put yourself
out there um you said I'm willing to
work to do whatever and I don't think
you
are I think you're allowing your fear
and doubt maybe combination of both you
may have fear hanging out on one
shoulder and doubt hanging out on the
other and fear by the way is is worry
that something bad is going to happen if
I move forward doubt is I don't believe
something good will happen if I move
forward very different but they gang up
on you and the fact that you've done the
hard work to get the licensing I
understand that building a successful
personal training business is sales yes
but it doesn't mean you have to start
there it doesn't mean you have to put
all your eggs in that basket it um and
and maybe just as George said earlier I
think it was a simple piece of advice
but I think it was profound just go work
at a gym man and and and and just get
your confidence up right and don't rely
on you know being self-employed per se
if you can get one of those jobs just
get in the industry get in there remind
yourself why you love you said the only
thing you've ever been passionate about
is the is the exercise the nutrition all
that goes into that you need to get in
that environment because what that will
do is get your heart re-engaged and give
you that what I call the juice but it's
just that
motivation that you need to overcome the
fear and the doubt that's what's missing
right now is you're not in that
environment to where it is igniting your
heart and giving you that real chemical
reaction that the brain sends to the
body a and and you're just kind of stuck
and you've had a tough time and we get
that we honor that but you need to get
in the zone man where you want to be get
in those places and then over time
you're going to start to get more
confident to go okay I see what it's
going to take to build a little side
business here and I start my physical
training business as a side hustle I
don't put all my eggs in that basket
that's what I want you to hear today
Christopher and and I think that you've
got this blanket on you of fear and
doubt and the only way to pull that off
is to actually step for forward one
little step at a time much like we
teaching the baby steps with get that
$1,000 you know baby step one and go oh
I accomplish that George I just think he
needs to get going yeah I mean Post in a
neighborhood Facebook group and go hey
I'm doing mobile Fitness I'll come to
you with a little bit of equipment and
I'll show you how to do this that's a
great way to get started at no cost to
you yeah and get some clients that way
and then work at the gym and start to
make connections hang on line I want to
send Ken's book proximity princip what I
was thinking yeah great minds think
alike it's it's unbelievable what's he
going to get out of that he's going to
get the Playbook on how to make
connections getting around the right
people getting in the right places an
opportunity show up on his doorstep
that's what that book does hang on the
line Christopher this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me
8825 5225 is the number to jump in and
George you told me during the commercial
break you were excited to tell me about
something what do you got on your mind
here this this is very exciting I never
know what you're going to hit me with
you like steak I love a good steak this
has to do with steak in a roundabout way
all right so Taste of Texas what is that
it's a restaurant in Texas I have no
affiliation they're not a sponsor but
they posted on Instagram and they tagged
us and here's the post can our team's
going to throw it up if you're watching
on YouTube oh they tagged us they tagged
us and here's what happened here's the
post okay today we celebrated 17 staff
members who completed Dave Ramsey's
Financial Peace University course nah
and I had a drawing and two winners got
$5,000 each to pay off credit cards and
get out of credit card hell Laura and
Jason were the lucky winners employees
were encouraged to pay the 80 bucks for
the course out of their own Pockets wow
then submit a completion certificate for
reimbursement of
$250 I see what they did there a 3 to1
bonus over the cost of the course wow
the names of the 17 who completed the
course went into the drawing for the two
prizes so proud of them and they threw
up a photo
oh those are the two winners that's
amazing but it made me think Ken because
you're in the workpace yeah imagine if
every employer Across America said hey
we want to do this for our team we want
to put them through Financial Peace
University or if you're an nhr an
employer smart dollar smart dollar is is
the corporate version of this how
encouraging is that to your team to go
hey we believe in you we know you guys
have money goals we're a part of that
because we're providing income for you
and your families we want to see you win
with money and pay off debt well I'll
tell you that's incredible it's a
benefit because here's what happens if
you as a leader or manager however you
want to do it tast of Texas was really
Innovative I thought pretty creative in
doing this not cover the cost but skin
in the game you cover it when you finish
it you'll get more than you put in I
love it it was a little bonus incentive
there I thought it was great uh what
happens is is the the end result of that
and I want to I want you to remind folks
again give us the averages because you
know it off the top of your head people
go through the nwe course of Financial
Peace University and they're saving how
much and paying how much off I believe
they pay off $5,700 in the first 90 days
and save $2,300 so it's an $8,000
turnaround in three months all right so
you take that number and as a manager
and as a leader you help your team
member get to that point in their life
and not just that initial turnaround I
don't want to get locked in on that
number but it's the momentum that comes
out of that that becomes an amazing
employee benefit and they're going to be
more engaged because they're not
stressed out with money yep so that
leads to higher productivity and higher
profitability there's higher morale yeah
but all team building exercise all that
leads to higher productivity and higher
profitability which you asked me the
question bottom line is it's a great
business growth strategy and in a day
and age where people are moving on
quicker they're not as loyal because
they don't get treated well candidly
sure it's a great leadership play well
and it says I believe in you and when
when a leader a company says I believe
in you I'm going to be more loyal to
that company and more I'm going to feel
like I'm going to stay longer so where
is this Taste of Texas at it's in
Houston oh we were I was just in Houston
for the national championship so I don't
know if they'll I'm sure I hope they end
up hearing about this because I started
looking at their menu Ken and I'm now
craving a tomahawk ribeye can you
imagine me Downing 38
ounces of ribey let me tell you
something it would take you three days
to eat 38 ounces you're little man I
think like the the TV networks would be
calling me saying we want to start a new
series called little man versus food
way more impressive I know that 38
ounces would give the meat sweats to
just about anybody Taste of Texas
congratulations on great leadership
George and I can be bought uh so this is
not an endorsement anyway but if you'd
like to send a gift card uh the next
time George and I are in Houston we
would love to come and we'll show up and
Sample the food and put it on Instagram
and if you want to check out smartd
dollar you can do that at
smartdollar.com it's our financial
Wellness benefit that you can offer to
your team we have huge companies that do
this exact U-Haul and Costco one of the
greatest personal benefits that a leader
can give to their team member is to give
them Financial Peace it's a huge huge
payoff by the way before we move on have
you ever had a Tomahawk Steak I did at
my my bachelor party oh that was the one
time how much did you eat did you pull
it up by the did you handle it like a
man well they ended up they brought it
out and then they took it back and cut
it for me to make it more palatable no
see if you're going to eat a Tomahawk
Steak you got to grab it and just chew
on it like Fred Flintstone that's what
you got to do with that I don't care
where you're at that's what you got to
do at least one bite wow I don't care if
it's a high futin you know hoyy toyy
festar Steakhouse I'm grabbing that
thing like Mike Gundy the head coach of
Oklahoma State said I'm a man got to
grab it lost you lost me when you
started talking about football you
should know better that's true uh I'll
explain it to him on the break folks if
you want to talk Madonna I can do that
all day but you can talk Madonna not
much me talking to you about college
football is is like
someone giving me a uh maybe like a
crash course on the planet Pluto you
know what I mean which doesn't even
exist anymore Pluto doesn't exist I
think they took it out of the running in
the textbooks that's not true it exists
it's just not classified as a planet
anymore conspiracy theory it's not real
James are you for real I didn't know
this this is pretty old news at this
point yeah decades old Ken okay I'm not
kidding you this is breaking news to me
I had no idea please tell me Uranus is
still a
planet that one's good yeah we're safe
all right all right let's move on Erica
is on the line in Minneapolis Erica how
can we help Hi how are you guys well I
hope you're okay given that last two
minutes you had doer I apologize you're
get that back but I hope you enjoyed it
that's all right a little uh lesson for
us all today I guess yes absolutely how
can we help I'm just calling because
I've got a question in regards to what
I'm being paid I currently work in
supply chain in the Minneapolis area and
I've been working as a buyer for about
seven years now for raw materials and
distribution and um Rec I have to go for
my annual review coming up here soon and
I'm just a bit nervous about what kind
of percentage I'm asking for when
looking at the duties required um to
move up to the next phase in my career
okay let's break it down so what are you
thinking let's just let's fast forward
to this meeting with your leader what
are you thinking you want to ask for
percentage wise as a
raise uh at least uh 8 to 10% 8 to 10%
what's that based
on uh I would just say just based on the
um like looking at ranges on salary.com
for what I'm being paid um and are those
are those ranges could you sit there in
front of me let's forget the boss for a
moment but could you explain it to me
right now to show that those are pretty
close to Apples to Apples as it relates
to your experience your skill set and
then the industry itself do you feel
like that's pretty fair to say that
you're being paid 8 to 10% less than you
should
be yes I mean in the in the industry the
ranges go from anywhere from 66 to
82,000 um a uh I am total compensation
for the year without any health benefits
or anything is I'm right at
665 okay so you're on the low range low
into of the r yes sir all right that's
really good so is your do you have some
anxiety over how to to bring this up is
that what you're asking and a bit of
anxiety and just when um my supervisor
gave me the position to move into a
buyer three and it seems that from the
way I'm looking at it and the work I'm
putting out every day the only
difference between a two and a three is
that it says you have to have expert
knowledge in the industry and materials
and you have to have a bachelor's degree
or 3 to five years of experience which I
do have both of those okay have they
brought up
compensation
um yes we did we did have a quite a few
layoffs this year um so I'm I think
that's what's giving me a bit of anxiety
is pushing back back um with people the
other buyer that I work with has said
that she got
5% um although she's only been there
about a year and a half so I'm just
that's good news for you that's good
news given that there's been layoffs
okay in 30 seconds I'm going to give you
the playbook for this that I give to
everybody you got to do your homework I
feel like you've done a good job on
homework and you go in you go look
here's the industry standard but you
also need to know that your leader is
probably not the sole Authority on this
approval probably got to go up so what
you got to do is not put them on the
defensive you got to make the case and
say hey I'm on the low end of the range
based on the industry standard I like
being here I want to be here I want to
grow uh and and and so this is where I'm
at on the Range I certainly like to move
up on the Range what can I do to help
you what's the measurement and that's
the conversation it's a posture of
humility and hunger not demanding this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campell joins me
8825 5225 is the number to jump in
that's
225 let's go to our scripture of the day
comes from Isaiah 54:17 when God is for
you no weapon formed against you will
prosper our quote now you don't know who
this guy is George
you don't know that yet who is it okay
you assume that you know what good call
I apologize I stand corrected maybe John
Wooden the great coach from that's where
you lost me I just know he he's got a
lot of great that's I'm impressed UCLA
I'm going to give you partial credit
UCLA University of California Los
Angeles for those that are keeping score
at home was not on my bingo card he was
called The Wizard of Westwood 11
national championships this is what he
said failure is not fatal but failure to
change might be and I think that has a
tie into Financial failure oh 100% I
mean Dave Ramsey story going through
bankruptcy in the 80s to building an
empire and helping Millions shame in
your game is what we like to say around
here uh so good stuff there from coach
John Wooden let's go to Aubrey now who
joins us in Houston Texas Aubrey how can
we
help hello how are you we are having a
blast today how are you great I'm good
I'm good good so so um I was wondering
whether or not I should sell 34 Acres
that I owner financed or just continue
to pay it wow tell us the details on the
land
itself so the land is strictly raw
there's nothing on it there were cows at
one point um it's fenced off for cattle
um but right now I don't have anything
actual like cattle based on it it's just
completely empty and it's raw land what
would you say it's
worth um it's worth about
200,000 um I got a quote from somebody
that if I were to sell it it' be about
$66,000 an acre um but that doesn't
include like their Commission of 6% from
the sell what do you owe on it and I
currently owe as of today um
$182,000 at a 1% interest rate okay what
do you think George well what was the
reason you bought the land in the first
place so I had bought the land in
conjunction of buying um another piece
of land that had a house on it um I had
got I was newly married and then in 2021
we started to go through a divorce so um
I got the 34 acres and then he kept the
other mortgaged um property however my
name was on it so it's going into Fort
closure here soon so I wasn't sure what
I should do because um I do have three
kids and I gross about 53,000 a year
almost 54 but take home is only about 35
34 with all the deductions that come on
my check and that doesn't include like
daycare rent vehicle insurance my phone
and then I have to have like a lawyer
fee and basically uh monthly I can bring
home about
$440 and then split that in half so it's
about 219 to spend on living and so I
don't even have oh my goodness auy I
feel your stress right now and anxiety
and for that reason alone even if this
was your dream to have this land and do
all this m magical stuff on it I'm
getting rid of this land and getting rid
of the payment and starting fresh I
agree you got three wonderful kiddos you
got a lot of life ahead of you and
you're restarting and part of the
restart is we had this dream we bought
this land the dream crumbled and now I
got to find a new dream and that's okay
but hey uh Aubrey you get out of this
thing unscathed essentially this land if
you sell it now you owe 182 and you walk
away with at least 182 after all the
fees well no not necessarily so I owe
and if I were to sell it at about 204
and then with the commission I would
probably walk away between 10 and
$12,000 after sale so yeah you would Net
10 grand yes around there depending end
up having to pay for closing cost or
anything sure do you have any any debt
outside of that um I have like $1,000 on
a credit card but my tax return is going
to come in I'm going to pay that off so
besides that that's good news and do you
have anything in SA
nothing okay and where are you living
right now rainy day fun uh right now I'm
cohabitating so I pay half rent but I
assume you want to get out of there yeah
I do okay so that is part of the reason
I would put a fire under your belly to
get rid of this property get out are you
what's the situation with the
kiddos um they live with me full time I
pay for everything I I haven't even got
my um final decree yet okay so nothing's
finalized
yeah I don't I don't receive any type of
um I guess you could say it's like child
support or anything it's just strictly
me doing it do you think that you will
get
any um I should be getting around a
thousand a month if okay if he my ends
up finalizing if he yeah that's to if he
pay is he a dead
meat uh right now yeah yeah well the
fact that you're taking care of him
fulltime tells me a lot yeah so we want
to we want to move forward let's assume
here's my point in asking that question
Aubrey it's not to add insult injury
here but George going forward I would
advise her let's assume he doesn't pay
anything so that if he does it's gravy
that would be my advice in this
situation I want you to be
self-sustaining in that way so here's my
plan if if I'm doing it my way and I was
coaching you one-onone Aubrey I was in
your shoes I would get rid of this land
you pocket the 10K that's going to
become your emergency fund let's get rid
of the credit card debt now let's go
find somewhere that we can rent for a
while with the kids and start fresh and
eventually I want you to be a homeowner
and have this new dream but right now we
just got to kind of clean up the mess
and get some Foundation under us as we
walk through this this terrible
situation yes sir okay what's your can I
ask real quick Aubrey about your
income yeah what are your income
possibilities if if if you and I were
just sitting at your kitchen table we
going okay how could we make 20,000 more
40,000 more 60,000 more what would you
say to me if I asked that question um so
and the line of work that I do um there
is a possibility that I could work like
every Sunday and make like
$160 so if I'm willing to sacrifice the
family time for money then that's an
option I think in the short term every
nickel at this point helps and the kids
are going to understand and you sit down
and explain it to them you're already
going through a very tough thing anyway
so you know you explain hey this is what
mom is doing and why um I think they're
just going to be so grateful for you and
your sacrifice kind of thing that they
may mention in a speech you know uh
graduating high school someday uh so I I
certainly would do that but I I'm
thinking bigger than
$160 you know what what can we do to
expand your income what's what's up the
lad or two or three
levels well um in April I'll get a
dollar raise and then the next go around
in January I should probably get another
dollar raise what are you doing for work
uh I work in law enforcement okay oh
okay okay do does you have good benefits
with
that um I mean the extra jobs that you
can work yeah is there overtime can you
work at a church doing security I don't
know what role exactly but are there
opportunities like that so yeah like um
working like an extra job like church
for like security that's what I usually
do on a Sunday is I'll go out and I'll
work okay and that's the0 Sunday okay I
try not to count it I try not to count
it just in case there's a time where I
you know
somebody else takes the job so I try not
to live off that so are you a deputy or
a police officer is that what I'm
understanding a police officer okay
great well thank you for your service by
the way not only are you a superhero as
as a single mom you also are out there
putting yourself uh on the line for the
citizens of your area and so you're
you're you're an absolute hero and and I
hope you feel that we certainly believe
that about you oh thank you well we we
answered a lot more than the question
Aubrey we apologize but I hope it helps
you take the right Next Step there's a
lot of steps to take but I hope we gave
you the right one right now which is get
rid of the land get some Financial
footing under you clean up all the debt
cut up the cards and find somewhere to
rent on your own and just get out of the
situation to some stability and safety
Aubrey real quick question how are you
doing on your budget do you feel like
you're strong at budgeting need a little
help what's going on there uh really
strong at budgeting the literally the
only bills that I pay is daycare rent
Vehicle phone and then of course have
like a lawyer fee just in case I'm sued
and then uh I pay like
for app uh for iCloud okay besides that
that's well hey I'm going to gift you
every dollar premium for the next year
just to alleviate one more thing and
give you one more tool in the tool belt
but we believe in you Aubrey and I hope
you believe in you you're going to get
through this and on the other side yeah
hang in there work the baby steps keep
going you're going to be great sell the
land it's going to give you tremendous
relief and take off a huge chunk of debt
George Campbell great show as always
always enjoy hanging out with you want
to think James Childs our fearless
leader and all the guys in the booth and
you America thank you so much this is
your show this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
a